pau 10 à 18 heures et à 22 heures
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat hier les sénateurs ont achevé une
partie de l'examen du projet de loi
grenelle 2 dont le chapitre consacré aux
bâtiments et à l'urbanisme
les sénateurs ont rétabli l'obligation
de l'avis conforme des architectes des
bâtiments de france pour toute
construction est réalisée dans les zones
protégées
je vous rappelle que cette disposition
avait été supprimée dans le projet de
loi grenelle 1 sous pression du
gouvernement et des députés de la
majorité
en revanche les sénateurs ont supprimé
hier une disposition qui avait pourtant
été introduite en commission par jean
bizet le sénateur ump de la manche
le gouvernement a jugé cette disposition
contraire à la loi littoral et il a eu
besoin des voix de la gauche pour faire
supprimer cet amendement ce qui a donné
lieu à une vive discussion dans
l'hémicycle que je vous propose de
revoir tout de suite
bon après midi à tous sur public sénat
article 14
je suis le président et maureen oui
merci monsieur le président charles
vinit speicher collègues
donc nous allons examiner que vous venez
de le dire monsieur le président
l'article 14 qui traitent des
compétences de l'architecte des
bâtiments de france et pour faciliter la
discussion j'ose espérer des amendements
déposés sur cet axe cet article je vous
demande d'examiner en priorité
l'amendement 364 de la commission de
l'économie et le numéro 68 rectifié bis
déposée par notre collègue ambroise
dupont nom de l'accord est de la
commission de la culture bien
alors donc je suis saisi d'une demande
de deux priorités
je vais consulter le ministre pour
connaître sa position sur cette demande
de priorité je vous cite eu simplement
le débat l'amendement 253 qui est dans
votre document a été retiré avant séance
et nous ou semi non vers cet amendement
est sous amendement en discussion
commune d'ansé cet amendement est sous
amendements figurent et l'amendement 35
et l'amendement 68 rectifié bis 2
abonnements sur lesquels jean-paul
emorine vient de demander la priorité
alors donc j'interroge de ministre pour
connaître son avis sur la priorité et
ils seront présentés au vote en priorité
mais tous les amendements s'empruntait
ministre sur la priorité et avis
favorable à huy favorable donc la
priorité est de de droit elle est donc
acquise et nous allons examiner les cet
amendement il sous-amendement diffusion
commune en commençant donc par de 364
qui est sous-amendé donc nous allons
commencer par le 364 puis le soin depuis
les sous-amendement les 364 le 68
rectifie vis puis les autres amendements
sont présentés alors monsieur braille
amendement 364 bon alors cette rédaction
rétabli une disposition commune à tous
les amendements examinés dans cet
article à savoir l'avis conforme de la
bf alors à la différence des amendements
précédent celui-ci réforme profondément
la procédure de recours contre l'avis
conforme de la bf en permettant aux
préfets de département de statuer en
dernier ressort et ce sans recueillir
obligatoirement avis de la commission
régionale des paysages et des si la
commission de l'économie a renouvelé
hier son attachement à cette version
qu'elle avait déjà voté avant l'été
mais je tiens à dire ici qu'il y avait
un certain nombre de sous-amendements
que naturellement les trois commissions
se seraient unis
nous avons aussi écouté je veux dire la
vie d'yves d'auge puisque bon tout le
monde sait que à la suite de ce qui
s'est passé dans la cmp du grenelle 1 le
ministre de la culture a souhaité mettre
en place une commission et que quel que
soit quels que soient ceux d'hier la
forme de la forme de l'article 14 que
nous proposerons je tiens à dire tout
simplement par transparence vis-à-vis de
la haute assemblée que nous attendrons
je dire les conclusions de la commission
mise en place par me lisent la culture
pour avoir une
une position définitive qui sera prise
naturellement en commission mixte
paritaire
mais la chose que nous souhaitons c'est
l'avis conforme après je dire toute la
procédure de recours doit naturellement
être amélioré et nous comptons sur
l'apport de cette commission qui a été
mise en place par le ministre la culture
donc ce qui me paraît important c'est de
voter l'avis conforme de façon à ce que
la discussion effectivement puisse
rester dirait que ça devienne en
commission mixte paritaire
et puis naturellement d'y intégrer aux
contres au cours cette commission mixte
paritaire
eh ben les éléments sur lequel nous
serons mis d'accord des conclusions de
la commission mise en place par nice de
la culture merci missionnant porter
alors que l'amendement 364 vient d'être
présenté et est accompagné de deux
sous-amendement un sous-amendement 454
rectifié terre je pense que c'est madame
dupont qui va nous représenter
chers collègues nous écoutons et de
demander un délai de réponse à
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
afin de ne pas faire laisser traîner les
dossiers comme il arrive souvent
alors il est possible je pense que le un
mois de réponse me paraît juste pour ce
genre d'administration mais on pourrait
porter à deux mois
alors c'est rectifié quater sur vous
non mais j'imagine qu'on va me refuser
le mois alors je propose dès maintenant
qu'on passe à 2 mois maximum
je vous repose la question s'agit-il
d'un rectifié quoi t'es assis c'est que
le règlement le nécessitent oui oui il
en moi j'ai une contrainte majeure c'est
quand je fait voter il faut que j'aie un
texte pour faire voter si je vous fait
voter sur une absence de textes
donc on reprendra le problème mais on a
entendu on a en même temps monsieur vous
n'avez pas les sous-amendement czeslaw
454 actifs yeter il est en principe dans
la liasse mais si vous n'avez pas en se
fera un plaisir de vous le faire
parvenir dans un délai très raisonnable
bien
alors maintenant on a un deuxième sous
un rendement toujours un amendement qu'à
présenter monsieur bras et c'est notre
collègue de lèche le présente c'est le
112 rectifier merci monsieur le
président cet amendement rectifié de la
commission des lois souhaite aborder
deux points particuliers
premièrement nous souhaitons clairement
que en l'absence de réponse du préfet au
terme gens viendraient tout à l'heure du
délai le recours soit réputé admis alors
qu'aujourd'hui le recours est réputé
rejetée donc tu as quelque sorte un
versement de la charge de la preuve et
deuxièmement nous souhaitons
effectivement le délai de saisine du
représentant de l'état dans le
département soit fixé par décret enfin
nous souhaitons que le préfet est
effectivement madame dupont deux mois
pour se prononcer non pas un mois un
mois pour des dossiers qui sont
quelquefois un peu complexe sur le plan
technique à regarder nous pas est trop
court et deux mois nous paraît beaucoup
plus raisonnable
merci mon cher collègue nous en arrivons
lamont 68 rectifié bis
quels autres collègues ambroise dupont
qui nous présente
merci monsieur le président dont le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques a réaffirmé avec la force
qu'on lui connaît est la conviction
qu'ils portent que nous étions très
attachés au maintien de l'avis conforme
des architectes des bâtiments de france
dans les alpes et et à huer le la
différence qu'il y as entre nos deux
approches tient au rôle à la fin ou
modalités du recours la commission des
affaires culturelles est attaché à ce
que le recours se fasse auprès du préfet
de région
parce que le préfet de région et celui
qui aujourd'hui rassemble les services
de l'état en matière de culture
deuxièmement la commission de la culture
tient aussi à la consultation de la crps
parce qu'elles considèrent qu'un avis
collégial dans un recours forcément
difficile est préférable à une décision
d'un seul d'une seule voix et enfin la
commission de la culture elle propose
que le délai soit imposé de deux mois
pour la réponse du préfet appelé en
recours voilà voilà ce que la position
de la commission de la culture crois
vous avoir dit l'essentiel de 2,7 de
cette position merci
alors nous en arrivons maintenant mais à
mon sens que ma priorité était demandée
étant présentés nous arrivons 254
rectifié bise qui est présenté par yves
dauge oui monsieur le président donc je
voudrais quand même à avant de parler
précisément de nos propositions rappeler
quand même un petit peu le contexte de
cette affaire
qui a été déclenchée par un élu d'une
autre assemblée
heureusement que la nôtre qui de plus
est se trouve dans un site du patrimoine
mondial
et je rappelle que l'état français quand
un site est classé à des responsabilités
vis-à-vis de l'unesco et s'est engagé à
faire respecter les règles les plus
strictes qui sont les nôtres donc déjà
nous étions dans une situation tout à
fait étrange de plus et je rappelle que
cette première tentative de mise en
cause des abf s'est faite dans le cadre
du plan de relance avec dans le fond un
procès d'intention que les architectes
des bâtiments de france ferait obstacle
au développement de l'activité et on a
revu alors le conseil constitutionnel
vous rappeler à est intervenue pour
arrêter cette opération mais on a revu
l'opération venir dans cette loi avec
l'idée toujours sous h 30 que les
architectes des bâtiments de france
ferait obstacle au grenelle 2 alors
heureusement que le sénat un toutes les
commissions et surtout des bancs a réagi
et j'ai apprécié l'intervention du
rapporteur
c'est vrai que le point central c'est
retour à la vie conforme
c'est ce que nous proposons aussi dans
notre monde ment je dois dire que nous
demandons aussi comme
le commission de la culture que les
recours se fasse au niveau de la région
avec l'avis de la commission du
patrimoine et des sites parce que ou
bien nous avons une commission un
collège avec des gens compétents qui
représente l'ensemble des compris des
associations qui peuvent s'exprimer
alors elle joue un rôle ou bien alors il
ya qu a considéré que cette commission
n'a rien à faire alors que le préfet
directement se substitue à la bfc que ce
qui n'est pas normal
il faut absolument que la commission qui
est une création importants soient mises
en situation de donner son avis alors
effectivement il ya la question des
délais je crois que nous nous disions
que à des crêtes de nos relais de l'ebe
est certain qu'il faut réduire les
délais et alors il faut qu'il y ait une
réponse obligatoire parce que s'il n'y a
pas de réponse obligatoire
effectivement on va se trouver dans la
situation que notre collègue a évoqué
tout à l'heure a pas de réponse vaut
quoi est ce que ça vaut accord ou pas
encore donc il vaut mieux qu'une réponse
absolument nécessaire delà de la
commission du préfet du préfet de région
voilà ce que je voulais dire merci mon
cher collègue alors nous en arrivons
maintenant un amendement 266 rectifié
bis qui est présentée par monsieur
jarlier oui il se présente ce mr qu'avec
cet amendement quant à supprimer
l'article 9 de la loi du grenelle du
connaît le vin pour rétablir
bien entendu l'avis conforme des
architectes des bâtiments de france
je reviens pas sur le contexte qui a qui
a amené à cette suppression de l'avis
conforme selon je veux redire que
c'était sans doute une fausse bonne idée
parce qu'elle aimait les maires en
première ligne dans des politiques qui
sont difficiles quelquefois à mettre en
oeuvre notamment en matière de
protection du patrimoine et et donc il
faut bien entendu conserver cet avis
conforme ensuite
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure les
arguments des deux amendements 364 et 68
il faut sans doute donné un délai
maximum d'instruction du dossier
mais il faut sans doute aussi s'assurer
que la saisine sera sera facilité mais
quand même temps la vie sera collégiale
donc il me semble que il serait
intéressant de trous de maintenir un
avis d'une commission
alors il ya une commission
départementale qui s'appelle la
commission des sites des paysages et des
sites peut-être peut-être pourrait-elle
être consultées autrement bien peut-être
qu'effectivement il faut aller comme le
propose monsieur dupont ouvert une
commission régionale même si on a plutôt
envie de voir ce type de difficultés ce
réseau de plus près du terrain sachant
que quand même on peut aller vers une
commission pourquoi parce que bien
entendu ces recours sont peu nombreux il
faut savoir que c'est de l'ordre de
pratiquement 1 2 3 pour 10000 pour 10000
d'instruction donc sans doute faut-il
s'assurer que les décisions qui sont
prises sont collégiales pour ne pas
laisser au préfet seul le soin de
décider
merci aux chers collègues
l'amendement 298 qui est présentée par
jacques muller l'objet de cet amendement
visait à rétablir la vie conforme sur le
fond on l'a bien compris qu'il en allait
à long terme de la qualité dans le
territoire en zppaup sur la méthode
aussi je suis sensible la façon dont on
travaille
le grenelle est une démarche
participative et je constate que tous
les milieux qui relève du patrimoine
avait insisté pour que l'avis conforme
puisse être maintenue donc je trouve
c'est une bonne chose mais cet
amendement introduit une autre dimension
c'est celle d'un besoin de régulation
je vous rappelle que sur l'article 4
j'avais mis en évidence des
et des contradictions manifestes de la
manière dont selon les territoires
les architectes se mettaient à
interpréter les choses et donc
l'amendement en question introduit un
référent supplémentaire en la personne
du préfet donc besoin de régulation
mais l'amendement aussi introduit un
deuxième principe le même que mon
collègue jarrier c'est celui du rôle de
la commission de la commission
le d cit qui doit pouvoir être
consultées donc régulation mais aussi
consultations élargies
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
et or écoutez je crois que nous sommes
au bout dé l'ensemble de la série
d'amendements excuses amendements en
discussion commune
donc c'est un portage est d'abord me
retournais vers vous pour connaître
votre avis sur ce qui n'a pas été
présentée par vous même
oui donc monsieur le président que nous
venons effectivement les trois
rapporteurs de façon relativement
discrète mais nous espérons
effectivement constructive de nous
consulter pour essayer et je le dis à
yves dauge il faut que nous sortions
effectivement du sénat ce soir avec une
position unie et forte si nous voulons
effectivement arrivé à l'assemblée
nationale sur quelque chose qui nous
permettra d'imposer quelque chose en
sachant que de toute façon quelle que
soit la position ce soir je le redis
kéos nous savons aussi qu'elle n'est pas
définitif puisque nous attendons les
conclusions de la commission mise en
place par le ministre la culture donc ce
que je proposerai puisque nous sommes
tous d'accord et que tout le monde
demande de rectifier effectivement la
demande mans de vue puisqu'il ne va pas
on a tous une position à plus différente
c'est que premièrement naturellement
nous maintenons la bvk conforme
c'est la première chose deuxièmement que
le recours effectivement que le délai
est effectivement de recours soit fixé à
2 mois que nous inversions la charge de
la preuve c'est à dire que si le préfet
n'a pas donné sa réponse dans un délai
de deux mois
le recours est réputée comme étant
adoptés et troisièmement que nous
allions pas devant le jet de le préfet
de département
comme je vous le propose mais devant le
préfet de région
voilà et pour l'instant ils doivent nous
en resterons là pour pas trop charger la
barque sans pour l'instant la vie de la
crds nous verrons un petit peu plus tard
je veux dire à la suite de résultats
mais donc avec ces quatre conditions
premièrement nous arrivons avec une
position qui est forte et qui est unie
et je souhaite effectivement que le
sénat ça fera aussi quelque chose
d'important vote à l'unanimité
effectivement ces dispositions puisque
les trois commissions et tous ceux qui
s'intéressent yves dauge aussi qui fait
partie effectivement de la commission
mise en place par me de la culture nous
venions comme un seul homme cette
disposition pour arriver devant
l'assemblée nationale en commission
mixte paritaire
je veux dire en ne pouvant tenir notre
position sur n'importe quoi je vous
entends bien je souhaite que nous
votions comme un seul homme que vous
votiez
mais je préfère que vous vous étiez
comme un seul homme sur un seul texte
donc moi je ne soumettrait malgré la
carte est votre exposé que si nous avons
un texte qui est autre chose qu'un
gribouillé à la main et je suspendrai de
temps nécessaire pour est en présence
d'un document qu'ils soient précis
monsieur le ministre je me suis permis
cette intervention de façon à ce que nos
collaborateurs puissent écrire
monsieur le président messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous sommes là devant un débat qui a eu
lieu à plusieurs reprises entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
et j'étais d'ailleurs député à l'époque
où ce débat a eu lieu et donc j'ai
évidemment pris part à l'assemblée
nationale je voudrais vous dire que vous
savez le ministre la culture va présider
une commission dont le rapporteur sera
le conseiller d'état thierry tuot des
parlementaires des deux chambres seront
évidemment associé à ce travail et donc
nous espérons qu'entre le texte qui
sortira du sénat et la semaine nationale
un accord soit trouverez entre
l'ensemble des partenaires pour que à
l'assemblée nationale au pire en cmp on
puisse avoir une position stable
définitive et qu'on arrête ces allers
retours incessants entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat qui ont deux
points de vue différents
je précise d'ailleurs que les points de
vue au fur et à mesure du temps commence
à se rapprocher entre les deux
hémicycles
qui va déjà me semble-t-il dans une
bonne direction pour ce qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui moi je serais assez
je vous proposerai la chose suivante sur
l'amendement 364 pré présentée à
l'instant par dominique braille
sous-amendé deux fois si j'ai bien
compris
une première fois pour passer au préfet
de région et une seconde fois avec
l'amendement du rapporteur de lège pour
mettre les deux mois j'émettrais un avis
de sagesse sur ces amendements la main
sur cet amendement ainsi sous-amendé
pour la raison suivante c'est que dès
lors que ce texte va évoluer me
semble-t-il notamment en lisant avec le
travail de la commission tuyaux il me
semble de notre point de vue en tout cas
nécessaire d'émettre un avis de crs
n'ont pas d'avis favorables chez lui ses
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance et je vous proposerai de la
reprendre
quand nous soient en possession du texte
rédigé complet et c'est à ce moment là
sur ce texte je pense que vous serez en
mesure de faire les explications de vote
que vous souhaitez faire pour marquer la
position des différents groupes
je pense que il est quelquefois intérêt
de prendre quelques minutes pour gagner
beaucoup de temps essayé de travailler
dans la clarté
même si ce n'est pas mon cher collègue
de la commission des lois toujours une
clarification rédactionnelles monsieur
raoul
je comprends très bien un intérêt d
avoir un texte tout à fait écrit etc
mais ce qu'on peut pas dans ce cas là
réservé l'article 14 en fin de
discussion et continuer à avancer non
non nous dans le texte si ça convient au
président de la commission europe
auteurs moi je suis d'accord et que je
suis d'accord avec cette solution
bon on fait comme ça alors
donc nous réservons la totalité de
l'article 14 et l'arctique après les
artic après la réplique à tort puisque
je suppose qu'ils ont un certain nombre
de choses à voir avec ce que sera
devenue une articles 14 et on va passer
si vous voulez bien
au passage qui est avant l'article 15
sur raul c'est vous
faut suivre un donc avant l'article 15
nous avons un amendement 273 rectifié
déposée par monsieur bailly les éval
il tombe avant l'article 15 un
amendement 199
je vais demander à evelyne didier de le
présenter merci monsieur le président en
fait le sens de notre amendement est
simple il s'agit de protéger et de
mettre en valeur les espaces agricoles
et naturels périurbains et les
départements suggère de revoir la
procédure d'acquisition du département
par préemption en proposant de placer ce
droit de préemption spécifique sous la
compétence directe du département et non
plus sur la compétence des safer les
élus départementaux propose de clarifier
sa mise en oeuvre à l'intérieur des
périmètres d'intervention délimité en
application de l'article l 143 1 du code
de l'urbanisme
vous avez compris qu'il s'agissait d'une
proposition qui nous venaient de l'as de
l'adf
merci mon cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur l'amendement
199 guen présente le président messieurs
mes chers collègues donc nul ne conteste
que la question est importante mais je
voudrais dire à hervé didier que cette
question devrait être abordée
prochainement dans le cadre d'une loi
qui doit être consacrée à l'agriculture
et qui nous paraît donc plus sage de
l'aborder à ce moment là donc c'est
pourquoi techniquement je vous
demanderais éventuellement en disant que
naturellement cette question doit être
abordée mais qu'il est plus sage de le
voir je dire tant la loi consacré à la
culture
c'est pourquoi je vous demanderais
éventuellement de retirer votre
amendement pendant l'engagement que ça
sera examiné à ce moment-là ministre
même avis monsieur le président madame
didier auzet solliciter votre position
là écoutez si j'ai la certitude que
c'est la question va être revue
prochainement
je vais retirer mon amendement vient un
moment 199 est retiré nous en arrivons à
l'article 15 à l'article 15 un
amendement 115 de notre collègue de lège
il fait allusion 14h14 vis je pense que
nous devons le réserver nous avons nous
arrivons à l'article 15
l'article 15 bis monsieur le ministre
c'est un amendement de suppression qui
est présenté par le gouvernement
c'est le rapporteur monsieur le
président on peut traiter celui là
monsieur le ministre nous vous écoutons
monsieur le président messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs cet article est pour nous un
article important et l'amendement de
suppression que nous vous proposons a
pour objet de ne pas toucher tout
simplement à la loi littoral
c'est une loi importante c'est ynwa qui
a nourrit évidemment beaucoup de débats
d'entre eux pays et nous sommes attachés
à ce qu'on ne remette pas en cause cette
loi pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'elle nous semble protégé actuellement
l'élite le littoral français
de même sur un autre registre la loi
montagne est tout aussi importante et
nous souhaiterions pas voir cette toile
y étais toi montagne remise en cause ce
qui est proposé par l'amendement qui a
été acceptée et voté en commission
c'est en fait de permettre dans la zone
des 100 m l'installation
de bergeries puisque s'il s'agit comme
on le sait tous des prés salés
d'installation de bergeries donc
d'équipements agricoles et puis un
deuxième élément dans cet amendement qui
est de dire que la mise aux normes des
bâtiments agricoles existants se peut se
faire de fait sans qu'il y ait de
contraintes nouvelles en matière de
rejet des bergeries en question c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes contre
nous sommes contre ce qui a été adopté
en commission et que nous souhaitons
bien évidemment que l'amendement soit
adopté nous ne souhaitons pas je me
répète que la loi littoral soit bouger
elle nous semble avoir atteint un bon
équilibre aujourd'hui et nous sommes pas
favorables à ce qu'on la touche
merci monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le président monsieur mise
des chers collègues donc une fois n'est
pas coutume je dirais j'en fait que ce
soit à la fin effectivement de l'examen
de ce titre que je sois en désaccord
avec la position effectivement du
ministre tout simplement pour dire que
la loi littoral n'a pas trouvé
effectivement réel équilibre puisqu'il
reste véritable problème entre vous le
savez le problème agricole des prés
salés et puis la conchyliculture donc
l'élevage des huîtres mais je laisserai
à notre collègue bizec est beaucoup plus
spécialisés que moi pour dire nous
souhaitons effectivement une loi terrain
et littoral mais nous ne souhaitons pas
non plus des territoires littoraux qui
soit complètement sanctuary zay et qui
ne permettent pas une certaine activité
se dire sanctuariser des territoires
c'est de toute façon à court à moyen ou
à long terme
les voir mourir tant que nous souhaitons
que puisse continuer je vais dire une
certaine activité donc l'amendement une
15 bis a été votée je rappelle à
l'unanimité à la commission des affaires
économiques
et puis la commission fait par ailleurs
remarquer que la dérogation qu'elle
introduit dans les dispositions
relatives à la voiture elle est très
encadrée puisque l'autorisation de
travaux est donné avec l'accord de
représentants de l'état dans le
département après avis de la commission
départementale compétente en matière de
nature de paysages et de sites et que
cet accord ait refusé
si les constructions ou installations
sont de nature à porter à
à l'environnement et aux paysages et
vous savez moi qui fais beaucoup de
bateaux je peux vous dire que de toute
façon voir des littoraux avec de jolis
bergerie avec des constructions bien
intégré dans le site s'est manifestement
beaucoup plus agréable que de voir
effectivement des paysages des paysages
changent rien là votre commission estime
que les dispositions de cet article
additionnel sont en cohérence avec les
amendements intégré au texte des
articles 6 et 9
cependant a souligné l'importance du
développement rural dans les documents
d'urbanisme les prés salés sont des
territoires vivante qu'il ne faut pas
mettre sous cloche et le législateur
doit donc concilier l'objectif de
préservation de l'environnement et celui
du développement rural cher à tous les
sénateurs qui sont ici voilà pourquoi je
suis contraint avec un immense
effectivement immense peine de donner un
avis défavorable je dire à l'amendement
du gouvernement bien alors ce métro voir
l'amendement 159
oui je vous ai vu qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission
explications de vote jean bizet et paul
raout
merci monsieur le président c'est le
président monsieur mes chers collègues
je comprends la réaction du gouvernement
face à ces deux amendements qui ont été
votés je le rappelle à l'unanimité en
commission des affaires économiques et
ce n'est pas un hasard c'est pas un
hasard c'est tout simplement parce que
si les élus locaux et dieu sait si on en
a parlé
le rapporteur l'a souligné à plusieurs
reprises au cours de cette soirée les
élus locaux sont des élus très engagé et
compétent sur ce plan là elles sont bien
conscients de l'importance de la loi
littoral de la richesse qui est ce
patrimoine de leur commune mais la loi
peut protéger mais tout doucement et au
fil des ans elle a dérivé et tout
doucement elle sanctuarisent ces
territoires
et si bien qu'il n'y a plus d'activité
économique il n'y a plus d'activité
agricole c'est ça la réaction si vous
voulez des élus c'est ça la réaction qui
a fait que
ce texte a été voté à l'unanimité moi je
suis très clair ce n'est pas une
atteinte à la loi littoral c'est
simplement un toilettage c'est une
amélioration comme il y en a déjà eu
deux fois par le passé depuis ces dix
dernières années qu'il y a deux clés de
sécurité
c'est que toute amélioration
construction mise aux normes qui entre
parenthèses je le rappelle est une est
une obligation réglementaire et qui
soeur précisément à je dirais à
l'étroitesse de cette loi littoral
si bien que je me trouve moi dans mon
département avec un statu quo sur un
certain nombre d'exploitations agricoles
où on préfère laisser en l'état et avoir
justement une pollution du rivage tout
simplement avec toutes les conséquences
sur la production des algues vertes et
c'est tout simplement parce que les
messi absolument et lé les les maires
les élus sont dans l'impossibilité
d'accorder si vous voulez des mises aux
normes par justement la rigueur de la
loi l'y talent dont il ya deux clés de
sécurité il faut l'accord du préfet et
l'avis de la commission départementale
des sites et paysages est en quelque
sorte il y à une inversion de la charge
de la preuve et il appartiendra au
préfet dans ce cas de figure de dire
pourquoi tel ou tel type de construction
ou l'aménagement porterait
éventuellement atteintes à
l'environnement
j'insiste bien sur ces territoires qui
sont des territoires fragiles que nous
devons protéger
il n'est pas question d'imaginer faire
n'importe quoi mais je me répète encore
une fois on glisse tout doucement de la
protection à la sanctuarisation et on
voit le développement d'un certain
biotope d'une certaine faune d'une
certaine fleurs particulièrement
indécise à un indésirable tant
visuellement je dirais que
l'écologiquement on parle beaucoup de
biodiversité et bien dans ces
territoires
il y a le développement et de la faune
et de la flore d'une flotte d'une faune
et d'une flore je dirais dominante très
dominantes qui va à l'encontre de la
biodiversité
moi ce que je ne voudrais pas
c'est que quinze jours comment dirais-je
on puisse voir après avoir entre
guillemets chasser l'animal domestique
de ces territoires et bien le risque
qu'un jour viennent tout simplement
qu'on voit l'homme à son tour et bien
déserté ce territoire personnellement je
le vis il n'est pas acceptable monsieur
le ministre il n'est pas acceptable que
nous en soyons à quatre années quatre
années de rédaction d'un cahier des
charges pour l'implantation de bergerie
dans la baie du mont saint michel côté
breton comme côté normand tout
simplement parce que entre les services
de l'état les services du conseil
général des services de la chambre
d'agriculture
chaque service ce renvoi ce dossier
quatre années pour écrire un cahier des
charges pour mettre en place des
bergeries alors que nous venons
d'obtenir une appellation d'origine
contrôlée sur je dirais ce type de
filière et que nous ne pouvons pas
précisément implanter des je dirais des
bâtiments agricoles pour pour organiser
la filière
voilà pourquoi je voulais moi je je ne
voterai pas bien évidemment la demande
du gouvernement pour explication de vote
paul raul puis jacques muller et
monsieur le ministre après puis venir
dédié celui france est mieux que vont
mes côtés différents groupes et que paul
roll out
non mais je pense quand même tourné sur
un sujet sensible et avec une force
symbolique extrêmement importante je
veux dire appartements ont touché dans
le cadre du grenelle 2 je dis bien dans
le cas du grenelle 2 à la loi littoral
j'imagine les commentaires demain dans
la presse nationale pour dire eh bien on
en a profité pour donner un coup de
canif à la loi littoral et faire en
sorte qu' on puisse installer des
activités agricoles en plus grand nombre
le long des littoraux franchement
franchement c'est pas dans l'esprit du
grenelle et la façon dont les choses se
sont déroulées
puis deux ans et quand on voit les
l'actualite les actualités du mois de
juillet du moins doux et les problèmes
littoraux avec les pollution avec tout
le scénario qu'on a vu et répétés à la
télé avec les algues à retirer et autres
types de pollution et le procès qu'il
nous ait fait ou qu'il est qui est fait
aujourd'hui à la société d'avoir laissé
faire je me vois mal aujourd'hui en
train de voter ce type d'amendements
alors je vous comprends bien monsieur
visez vous dites oui bah mon département
la manche
etc mais au-delà de ça je veux dire il
ya une façon de maîtriser l'activité
économique sans toucher à ces littoraux
qui obéissent à une loi à une grande loi
qui aujourd'hui est respectée que l'on
essaie de faire respecter et troubler
l'équilibré de cette loi aujourd'hui ne
paraîtraient pas judicieux et
franchement après tout ce qu'on a pu
dire tout ce que vous avez pu dire mais
tout ce que nous avons dit
collectivement en votant à l'unanimité
le grenelle 1 je pense que si on vote ce
texte ce soir
franchement ce sera une façon d'aller
contre tout l'esprit du grenelle tel que
nous l'avons voulu tel que nous l'avons
défendue et vous parler de
sanctuarisation mais oui il ya des
espaces qu'il faut sanctuariser qu'il
faut protéger parce que la biodiversité
l on ne peut pas y toucher comme ça
impunément et des tannes éléments de la
planète et de l'équilibré de la planète
et de l'homme dans la planète et que
nous faisons partie cette biodiversité
et les littoraux la frange littorale
elle est quand même je dirais
aujourd'hui dans vingt deux dans une
situation d'insécurité par rapport à
cette biodiversité c'est l'élément le
plus fragile aujourd'hui tellement le
reçoit d'agression et je voudrais pas
que à travers cet amendement on puisse
dire eh bien finalement on a laissé
faire des choses que l'on ne doit pas
laisser faire voilà c'est tout enfin
pensez au moins un lâche
car symbolique de l'amendement que vous
êtes en train de proposer mois les bras
m'en tombent
et on peut pas accepter a tellement
demain je le dis sans esprit polémique
mais vraiment il ya là une force
symbolique que qu'on ne peut pas comme
ça enlevez supprimé par la façon dont
vous présentez durable donc je me suis
vu les accus madame didier et après le
ministre le rapporteur est le président
de la commission mais on laisse
l'ensemble des groupes ces crimes
similaires sur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
méthode
alors effectivement ayant participé à la
réunion de commission ou ce point a été
abordé
j'entends ici le rapporteur collègues
bizet insisté sur le fait que nous avons
voté à l'unanimité
alors oui je me suis abstenu maintenant
ma collègue evelyne didier j'ai ici le
compte rendu de la réunion a indiqué
n'être pas en mesure d'en apprécier la
portée les conséquences s'était abstenu
aussi parce que lorsqu'on n'a pas tous
les éléments techniques sur un dossier
comme ça on s'abstient donc c'est pas
une unanimité
parce que tout le monde lève la main et
soutient c'est parce qu'on était dans la
certitude
moi je vous dis franchement lorsque j'ai
découvert
l'argumentaire la réflexion développée
par monsieur le ministre
alors il je vous invite tout à l'heure à
le développer monsieur le ministre pour
que toute l'assemblée l ensemble d'idées
aussi grâce à sa complexité
moi j'ai été convaincu j'ai été
convaincu ici que nous prenons un risque
un risque terrible de décrédibiliser le
grenelle dans ma dg mardi j'avais dit le
diable se niche souvent dans les détails
ben nous y voici nous y voici à partir
d'un amendement anodin susceptible de
régler un problème local
et puis c'est sympathique aussi les
moutons
de pré salé on prend ici une disposition
qui risque effectivement de tuer
l'esprit de la loi littoral en tout cas
de la déséquilibrer gravement
alors je n'aurais pas l'outrecuidance de
de lire ici le texte qu'à rédiger ou que
les services du ministre ont rédigé mais
je souhaite vraiment monsieur le
ministre je souhaite vraiment monsieur
le ministre que vous puissiez parce que
les collègues ici ont pas eu le temps de
lire votre argumentaire il est très fin
il est détaillé
il est technique il est précis bien moi
je vous demande de l'exposé précisément
devant ce le rapporteur je ne vous ai
jamais interrompue s'il vous plaît je
vous demande donc solennellement de
développer ce point là on en aura tous
besoin pour comprendre ce qui se passe
et à ce moment là nous montrons tous en
notre âme et conscience
plutôt que de suivre mécaniquement une
commission qui auraient voté à
l'unanimité
alors que deux fait nous n'avons pas eu
ce débat technique en commission merci
je suis le même didier puis monsieur le
ministre
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bon jeu
j'allais dire ce que vient de dire mon
collègue muller à savoir que
effectivement nous ne mesurions pas là
parfaitement la portée et est donc
effectivement c'est un amendement
maintenant qui est celui de la que c'est
un article qui est maintenant celui de
la commission pour autant ça veut ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on a approuvé loin de
là aujourd'hui après avoir effectivement
lu ce que vient d'écrire le gouvernement
d'une part en me rappelant aussi les
débats que nous avons eu à d'autres
moments sur d'autres textes concernant
justement cette loi littoral on sait
qu'elle est très contraignante
on sait que d'aucuns veulent lui faire
des accrocs et veulent essayer d'en
diminuer la portée
je me dis qu'on fond on est dans un
titre qui s'intitule bâtiment et
urbanisme
et qu'au fond ce cet article là c'est un
cavalier et que ce n'est pas fair bonnes
manières que d'attaquer une loi aussi
fondamental aussi importante de cette
façon là ça mérite près de toute façon
un débat un autre moment qu'à une heure
du matin en catimini alors qu'on ait si
peu nombreux
je crois que ça mérite mieux et donc je
ne je voterai pour l'amendement du
gouvernement
merci monsieur collègue monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bizet je ne peux
que comprendre l'exaspération quatre ans
pour rédiger un cahier des charges pour
bâtir les bergeries en question je
trouve ça comme tout comme vous pardon
exaspérant alors si je vous dis
aujourd'hui que je prends l'engagement
solennel devant vous de régler ce
dossier là et d'établir ce cahier des
charges dans les trois mois qui viennent
vous pourrez tout est effectivement de
la parole delta dès lors que ça fait
quatre ans qu'on vous fait lanterner je
prends quand même cet engagement devant
vous si vous acceptez de retirer cet
amendement
pourquoi je comprends bien votre refus
pourquoi parce que ce qui me gêne dans
votre amendement c'est que pour un
exemple pour un cas particulier qui est
le vôtre qui est juste on a un
amendement d'une portée générale un
moment d'une portée générale qui ne se
limite pas aux cas précis qui est le
vôtre mais qui va beaucoup plus loin en
autorisant toutes les constructions de
bâtiments à usage agricole dans la bande
des 100 mètres
qu'il s'agisse des moutons du mont saint
michel ou de toute autre forme
d'agriculture dans la bande des 100
mètres
nous avons donc là un dispositif d'une
portée générale qui porte nous
semble-t-il atteinte fortement à la loi
littoral alors que vous souhaitez
ce qui est très compréhensible régler un
cas particulier juste c'est la raison
pour laquelle
le gouvernement est évidemment maintient
cet amendement et souhaite le défendre
devant vous j'ajouterai un second point
si vous le voulez bien qui me paraît
tout aussi important votre amendement
comporte deux parties la première partie
nous venons de l'évoquer
la seconde partie c'est celle que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure peut être un
peu rapidement de la mise aux normes la
mise aux normes
aujourd'hui elle est possible elle est
possible à une condition c'est que cette
mise aux normes n'entraînent pas une
augmentation des effluents des animaux
avec votre amendement vous permettez une
mise aux normes mais vous retirer cette
condition d'augmentation des effluents
des animaux autrement dit j'ai essayé de
prendre un exemple très concret qui ne
reflétera peut-être pas une réalité
imaginons un cas d'espèce en bretagne
une porcherie existe dans la zone des
100 m nous avons 20 cochon dans la
porcherie en question ont fait une mise
aux normes et on estime aujourd'hui que
cette mise aux normes entraîne des
effluents de x avec la partie 2 de
l'amendement
on pourra à faire une mise aux normes
avoir une porcherie qui va doubler
tripler de volume et avoir donc des
effluents qui double de volume
aujourd'hui la loi permet d'ores et déjà
la mise aux normes en question elle
permet la mise aux normes en question à
condition qu'il n'y ait pas une
augmentation des effluents ces salles
élément important et dont votre
amendement vous permettez la mise aux
normes en question ce qui est le droit
actuel mais vous supprimer la condition
que je viens d'évoquer
qui est pour nous très importante parce
que vous savez comme nous que ce sont
ces effluents question qui produisent
les algues vertes qui font aujourd'hui
des balles entre territoires voilà
peut-être avec un peu plus de précision
les raisons pour lesquelles nous avons
proposé cet amendement je comprends là
encore monsieur le sénateur je comprends
le cas particulier vous évoquez je
propose qu avec vous prouve une solution
dans les trois mois qui viennent parce
que vous avez raison pour ce qui
concerne votre dossier mais là vous avez
un amendement d'une portée générale qui
me semble-t-il ne répond pas à votre
propre ambition
monsieur en porter
mais oui suis visé s'est déjà exprimée
en explications de vote et ils ne
proposent pas d'amendement monsieur
bizet n'a pas d'amendement il il a
expliqué son vote hostile à l'amendement
de suppression du gouvernement en
défendant la position de la commission
si j'ai bien compris
alors monsieur visé josaine la parole
mais bon on va je crois que dans le
climat on peut se permettre une petite
entorse qui va faciliter je pense
quelque chose
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre m'a fait une proposition très
aimable mais il comprendra que je ne
peux pas l'accepter
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
un cas particulier
nous visons les uns et les autres le
même objectif
c'est à dire protéger un environnement
fragile spécifique mais qui a besoin
précisément de la présence d'animaux
domestiques sur ce territoire comme il a
besoin également de professionnels liés
à l'exploitation
je dirais des espaces marins pour faire
de la conchyliculture ou autre je sais
très bien que si vous voulez en ayant
déposé ce texte une onde entre
guillemets de choc et cette question de
l'augmentation des effluents mais il est
bien évident que l'augmentation des
effluents dans le cadre de la mise aux
normes
ce ne sont pas des effluents qui vont
polluer le territoire sont des effluents
qui sont gérés qu'ils sont pratiques qui
sont particulièrement gérer puisque nous
sommes dans des obligations
réglementaires alors qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de possibilité de mise aux
normes sur certains établissements
agricoles parce qu'on se heurte à la
régie dit et de la loi littoral au
travers de l'article 140 6-4 donc nous
avons le même objectif
parce que moi je le dis très clairement
demain si nous désespérons autant les
agriculteurs ou les gens qui vivent dans
ces territoires
et qu'ils n'ont pas il n'y a pas de
porcherie chez moi sur le souhaitent non
mais je ne peux pas pris ça comme comme
une agression
il n'y a pas ni de d'élevage hors sol
qui porcherie niveau là ils n'ont pas
besoin d'être sur ces espaces de
territoire on a besoin tout simplement
d'herbivores donc de moutons de bovin
voire descoings tout simplement parce
que chaque espèce animale à sa vocation
sur ces territoires pour consommer tel
et tel type d'herbe
j'ai dans une partie de la baie du
mont-saint-michel en bordure précisément
de de la bretagne une telle
prolifération de ronces de deux
mauvaises herbes qu'il n'y a plus d'eau
bionne qu'il n'y a plus de bionne qui
est l'herbe qui permet aux moutons prés
salés de se développer qu'il n'y a plus
de salicorne et et ce sont des mauvaises
herbes
c'est un biotope qui n'est pas favorable
à je dirais à un environnement de ce
type de qualité donc je suis tout aussi
empreint que vous aimez collègues de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle de cette
notion de développement durable
je vous ferai pas l'affront de rappeler
les trépieds du développement durable
mais là si vous voulez comme on occulte
totalement la donne économique il n'y a
plus d' équilibre au niveau
environnemental et et sociale et ce
n'est pas un cas uniquement dans le
département de man je me suis renseigné
dans le finistère c'est pareil je ne
voudrais pas si vous voulez j'en
terminerai par là je fait loi déjà été
toilettée deux fois je vous propose de
l'artois l'été une troisième fois et
c'est pas dans mon esprit de lui porter
atteinte c'est simplement de l'améliorer
j'ai des rapports les plus courtois avec
les services de l'état sur ce point mais
très sincèrement il y à la loi il y à la
lecture de la loi il y à l'esprit de la
loi
et permettez moi de dire il y a
également l'ouverture d'esprit d'un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires au
niveau départemental avec lesquels on ne
peut pas quatre années quatre années et
ce n'est pas terminé
quatre années pour élaborer
il décharge c'est pas possible monsieur
le rapporteur oui d'abord de réflexion
rappeler d'abord à monsieur muller
effectivement que nous étions un certain
nombre en tout cas le rapporteur gvir
d'avoir pris connaissance complètement
de l'argumentaire fin argumenté et
précis effectivement de monsieur le
ministre est que nous nous sommes
présentés prononcé en totale
connaissance de cause premièrement
deuxièmement dire à notre collègue raul
tu que de toute façon peut-être que la
presse en france au machin j'estime que
l'environnement je dirais plus important
effectivement que les problèmes que les
journalistes vont faire et pour moi ce
n'est pas du tout un argument pertinent
je me permets de le lui dire ce que la
presse d'hier à demain et dire après
demain je veux dire ça passera vite
alors que les problèmes d'environnement
je veux dire dureront bien plus
longtemps
dont dire que de toute façon et je suis
étonné d'ailleurs au moins que jacques
muller qui nous dit effectivement et qui
de par sa profession
je dirais dire que de toute façon ils ne
soient pas conscients et que les gens ne
soient pas conscients que la situation
actuelle qui se développe dans la loi
littoral quand en et des espaces sont
sanctuarisés cela porte une grave
atteinte à la biodiversité
on pourrait le démontrer notre collègue
jean bizet nous l'a dit et je refuse
alors de toute façon totalement
catégorique ce que vient de nous dire le
ministre sur le problème effectivement
de la porcherie
je vous signale qu'il dit est ici des
des barrages et que nous avons et nous
habille revient dit le monsieur bizet
nous l'a dit que de toute façon la
commission départementale compères pas
pour demain tiers et puis aussi que la
des paysages et des sites et que ça que
c'était cet accord est refusé si les
constructions ou installations sont de
nature à porter atteinte à
l'environnement
donc il est bien évident que à partir du
moment où il y aura des effluents qui
seront considérablement augmenté pour le
cas de la porcherie
il est bien évident que la commission
compétente prenant acte je dire de
l'atteinte grandissante à
l'environnement par rapport à la
situation antérieure donnera un avis
défavorable donc votre argument monsieur
le ministre que vous avez soutenu ne
tient pas je veux dire puisque monsieur
bizet avait prévu se garde
ou pour éviter la position effectivement
que vous venez de décrire donc je
voulais dire les algues vertes allons
les laisser ce que l'on voit se
développer effectivement puisque la
diversité biologique est en train et
vous avez vous êtes en train d'assister
dans ces territoires que l'on traite en
train de s'autoriser je dire tout
simplement de la prédominance d'espèce
je dire de végétaux qui sont en train de
prendre le pas sur eva tout simplement
la flore naturelle
donc je vous le dis et je le dis je dire
à mes collègues très sincèrement ce
problème est un problème important pour
l'environnement
et tant pis pour les journalistes pour
la biodiversité
il me paraît important de voter 2 contre
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
casse bis que nous avons voté à
l'unanimité
alors mes chers collègues je ne donnerai
plus la parole à personne parce que
j'estime de l'assemblée suffisamment
éclairé monsieur le président est mort
et nous et nous on est depuis longtemps
josé on écoute le voisin et on passe au
vote
je pense qu'il ya un moment où on peut
continuer inlassablement je dirais j'ai
bien vu tout votre crainte que ça dure
longtemps sur la bf donc vous allez
trouver un dérivatif aux seuls
présidents vous avez la parole oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je prends
la parole c'est pour éclairer quand même
le débat de la commission parce que je
peux pas laisser dire notre collègue
muller qui a pas eu débat en commission
jack depuis le début de ce texte le
ministre nous avons été en liaison
permanente les rapporteurs de la
commission avec avec le gouvernement
avec vos collaborateurs
nous avons un différend par rapport à
cet amendement qui était adoptée un
moment donné qui était inscrit dans le
texte de la commission
le gouvernement dépose un amendement ce
qui peut apparaître tout à fait naturel
quand on a abordé ce sujet en commission
c'est l'exemple de la porcherie je
m'excuse monsieur le ministre c'est pas
le bon exemple
ce que jean bizet nous expose ce que
j'ai en tête c'est que nous avons des
espaces naturels à préserver ce qui
paraît bien sûr la moindre des choses
mais que peut-on constater son fait des
projections à 10 20 ans ou 30 ans
la biodiversité monsieur le ministre
n'est pas tombée du ciel cette
biodiversité et les venues de l'activité
d'élevage et mon cher collègue et nous
nous connaissons suffisamment je
soutiens pas l'élevage porcin dans ces
espaces
mais quand vous avez des élevages bovins
ovins ou et qu'un comme l'a dit jean
bizet souvent ce qui vous amène la flore
dans ces espaces qui sont à protéger
aujourd'hui c'est cette activité
d'élevage ce que nous avons voulu aux
côtés de jean visite de jean bizet c'est
de préserver un élevage extensif qui
entretiennent cette biodiversité
pourquoi nous avons voulu faire pour
préserver dans le temps monsieur le
ministre la biodiversité
je vais vous donner un exemple dans le
monde département et j'ai dans mon
département
j'avais action 2 avec son accord je
voulais rapidement s'ils loupent je
serai très bref je n'aime pas qu'on dise
des choses qu'on fasse qu'on mettre dans
ma bouche des choses que je n'ai pas dit
jeudi très précisément nous n'avons pas
eu de débat contradictoire technique et
précis sur les conséquences de cette des
amendements présentés par mon collègue
disait j'ai pas dit qui a pas eu débat
j'ai dit que on a eu une information
quasi unilatérale et nous étions un
certain nombre à s'abstenir par
courtoisie
parce que nous n'avons pas l'habitude de
prendre position lorsque nous n'avons
pas les éléments
donc on ne peut pas dire que la la
commission comme un seul homme a voté à
l'unanimité par honnêteté intellectuelle
moi quand je ne sais pas je m'abstiens
et bien aujourd'hui je sais vous n'avez
pas la parole aux seuls que la lozère
s'est ouvert le procès de mal diriger
cette commission que j'ai toujours l'été
objectif je vous ai toujours entendu
vous aviez les éléments de l'amendement
du gouvernement c'est à dire que vous
aviez les informations et que quand nous
avons procédé au beau vote
nous avons eu un débat ya des témoins
sur les bancs socialistes et communistes
nous avons eu un débat le rapporteur est
intervenue jean bizet intervenue et je
suis intervenu personnellement dans les
mêmes termes que je m'adresse en séance
tout à fait mais je ne porte pas de
jugement sur vos positions
monsieur muller nous dit que vous êtes
abstenu ce que dit dominique braye quand
on analyse un vote
s'il ya un vote ici à des abstentions on
compte ça s'appelle un vote unanime donc
choix qu'il a la fidélité mais que vous
ayez toute latitude pour vous exprimer
je ça me convient tout à fait ce que je
veux dire par l'exemple monsieur le
ministre que je veux vous citez dans le
département de saône et loire
j'étais d'accord pour la préservation
d'une réserve naturelle et le
département à participer à la au
financement de cette réserve naturelle
parce qu'il y avait une diversité
biologique à travers des dunes à travers
une flore
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
protecteurs de la nature ou ont voulu
empêcher les animaux d'y pénétrer
vingt ans après que constate-t-on une
friche où il ya des vip un mois je
défend la position de jean bizet pour
préserver la biodiversité
mais en même temps maintenir une
activité économique respectueuse de
l'environnement
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes contre la
bande du gouvernent
alors nous allons passer au vote si vous
le voulez bien
sinon je devoir suspendre vous allez
devoir revenir demain alors nous avons
je paie l'amendement 159 qui a été
présenté au nom du gouvernement par le
ministre qui est pour
l'amendement présenté par le ministre
qui est contre
l'amendement est adopté et par voie de
conséquence n'a plus que 15 bis est
supprimée monsieur le ministre
après vote
j'aurais juste confirmé l'engagement que
j'ai pris tout à l'heure auprès du
sénateur bizet dans les trois mois qui a
des charges sera réglé dans ce vote qui
lui tout le monde sera d'accord pour
dire qu'il n'était pas unanime dans ce
vote l'amendement 255 et bien évidemment
trouver alors je vous propose qu'on
finit ce qui concerne le 15 vices et
caetera et puis on va revenir après à la
bf alors après l'article 15 juillet un
article additionnel 1 1
un amendement 225 qui est présenté par
mais bien sûr en chers collègues je
voudrais tout simplement fait faire un
petit incidente avant de présenter cet
amendement c'est ce qui s'est passé ici
ce soir et par rapport à l'évolution du
travail législatif en commission fera
que notre groupe systématiquement votre
à contre les amendements de la majorité
en commission
ça évitera toute interprétation
concernant des votes unanimes comme ça
ce sera clair même si après en séance
ont pour aller voter
ça évitera une manipulation des votes et
des abstentions ce que je trouve pas ça
très honnête monsieur le rapporteur
je vous trouve pas très correct ce soir
d'ailleurs ça fait 3 remarque que je
vous ai déjà fait c'est 1h05 du matin je
pense qu'il faut garder un certain calme
donc monsieur raoult la seule la parole
et on en revient à son amendement 225 je
pense qu'on s'est exprimé que vous aurez
l'occasion de continuer donc mon cher
collègue vous avez seule la parole
j'espère monsieur le président que vous
aurez l'occasion de donner la parole aux
rapporteurs sinon il va exploser
la production de logements dans le
respect du développement durable
nécessite une offre dans ce foncier en
milieu urbain
et l'état doit donner l'exemple à cet
effet il convient d'élargir les
possibilités qui lui sont offertes de
céder du foncier avec des cotes pour
produire des logements abordables dans
le cadre de la loi un nl nous avons déjà
adopté ce qui est désormais l'article
l331 1200 ce tir et 7 du code général de
la propriété des personnes publiques qui
permet à l'état de vendre des terrains
de son domaine privé à un prix inférieur
à la valeur vénale lorsqu'ils sont
destinés à la réalisation de programmes
comportant essentiellement des logements
dont une partie de logements sociaux
le présent amendement a pour objet
d'étendre cette possibilité aux
constructions sachant qu'ils qu'il ne
s'agit pas de permettre ou d'imposer de
telles cessions
c'est une seule possibilité on cherche
avec monsieur dont l'un porte sur l'avis
de la commission sur l'amendement 225 ch
et rapporteur naveed la commission sa
d'amendements 225 et je sollicite votre
parole
alors la loi grenelle a permis à l'état
de vente des terrains de son domaine
privé un prix inférieur de la valeur
vénale lorsqu'ils sont destinés à la
réalisation de programmes comportant
essentiellement des logements sociaux
le présent amendement a pour objet
d'étendre cette possibilité aux
constructions
sachant qu'il ne s'agit que de permettre
et non d'imposer de telles cessions
donc c'est un avis favorable
effectivement pour la construction des
logements sociaux
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
monsieur le président bien je vais
mettre aux voix s'il n'y a pas
d'explications de vote l'amendement 225
qui et pour qui et contre l'amendement
est adopté
alors après l'article 15 800 amendements
226 qui est présenté pour le groupe
socialiste par
la loi de finances pour 2009 autorise
sous certaines conditions la cession à
l'euro symbolique aux communes des
immeubles domaniaux reconnu inutile par
le ministère de la défense dans le cadre
des opérations de restructurations
militaires réalisées entre le 1er
janvier 2009 et le 31 décembre 2014
il est proposé d'étendre cette
possibilité de cession à l'euro
symbolique au bénéfice d'organismes hlm
ou au sam lorsque des besoins logements
sociaux ont été mis en évidence par un
plh
ceci notamment pour éviter que des
projets solides soient retardés ou
simplement à journée parce que la
cession ne peut pas être faite au profit
de ses établissements publics
cette proposition s'inscrit donc dans la
même logique que la main que
l'amendement précédent il s'agit de
résoudre des petits problèmes techniques
ou des freins technico administratif
auquel les praticiens sont confrontés
sur le terrain pour mettre en oeuvre des
projets qui pourtant font l'unanimité
merci à eux seuls que l'émission
rapporte rêver de la commission oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc la
commission avait donné éventuellement
l'avis favorable à condition qu'ils
soient rectifiées comme il n'a pas été
rectifiée c'est un avis défavorable
sinistre oui monsieur le président mais
même avis que le rapporteur avis
défavorable il s'agit là de cession à
l'euro symbolique
nous sommes en plus totalement en dehors
du texte que nous examinons à l'instant
c'était d'ailleurs la même chose mais
erreur d'inattention de ma part sur
l'amendement précédent serait dû émettre
un avis défavorable parce que nous
sommes totalement en dehors du texte et
il s'agit là évidemment de cavaliers
législatifs ou bien pas d'explications
de vote je me vois l'amendement 226 qui
est pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée après l'article 15 lui sa maman
non 227 paul raul
vise à inciter donc et particuliers
entreprises qui souhaitent céder les
immeubles appartenant à privilégier les
ventes à destination du secteur du
logement social la loi 2005 que 841 du
26 juillet 2005 a prévu une fiscalité
allégée en cas de vente un organisme de
logement social hlm ou scène à savoir
une exonération d'impôt sur les
plus-values les particuliers et
l'application d'un taux réduit d'impôt
sur les sociétés sur les plus values des
entreprises ce système a porté ses
fruits en particulier à paris
c'est pourquoi nous avons pensé qu'il
pourrait être intéressant de favoriser
ce type de cession de la part des
entreprises
nous proposons donc d'aligner le régime
applicable aux entreprises sur celui des
particuliers
c'est à dire de leur consentir une
exonération totale d'impôt sur la plus
value ceci serait bénéfique pour la
lutte contre l'étalement urbain et pour
garantir une offre supplémentaire de
logements sociaux et dans le même temps
cela peut être une solution intéressante
pour certaines entreprises qui
souhaiteraient se procurer des fonds
propres
monsieur sur un porteur avis de la
commission
oui monsieur le président monsieur lui
ce déchet recueille la commission avait
donné avait souhaité demander l'avis du
gouvernement et suivra l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre un
avis défavorable là aussi il s'agit d'un
cavalier et donc la vie sera évidemment
défavorable sur cet amendement là
j'ajoute ce que pour les amendements
précédent sur la série qui sont en train
d'examiner
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler avec le
président repentance et mid semer dit je
lui ai donné ce même avis là nous sommes
sur une loi qui s'appelle le grenelle 2
faces et passons son nom évidemment mais
c'est le grenelle 2 nous ne sommes pas
là sur une loi sur le logement
très bien je soumets au voile amendement
227 kg et pour qui et contre
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
la pratique injuste en amont aux 282
jacques muller où il ya actuellement les
délits en matière de protection du cadre
de vie prévue par l'article l 581 34 du
code de l'environnement doivent être
jugés par un tribunal correctionnel
composé d'un président et deux
assesseurs
ce qui peut expliquer en partie la
rareté des poursuites en la matière en
effet dans la mesure où les procureurs
de la république accorde généralement
une priorité aux infractions commises
contre les biens et les personnes
ces infractions jugées au cadre de vie
jugés non prioritaires sont d'autant
moins susceptibles de faire l'objet de
poursuites cette situation me paraît
d'autant moins justifié que l'article
398 1 du code de procédure pénale
prévoit déjà dans son sixième que
certaines infractions au code de
l'environnement de nature délictuelle
peuvent être jugé par un tribunal
correctionnel composé d'un juge unique
ainsi l'extension de cette possibilité
aux délits commis en matière de
protection du cadre de vie ne pourrait
qu inciter les procureurs de la
république a engagé plus fréquemment des
poursuites et ainsi à contribuer tout
simplement au plus grand respect de la
loi en la matière la commission a donné
un avis défavorable se poser au ministre
d'avoir rappelé également monsieur
président bien je me vois l'amendement
289 qui est pour et qui est contre il
n'est pas adoptée jours à peine que les
amendements numéro 63 73 partant
division article additionnel après
l'article 15 villes ont déjà été
examinés en priorité division
additionnel après l'article saint-louis
qu'un article 309 monsieur muller un
amendement 309
cet amendement vise à créer un nouveau
chapitre à la fin du titre 1 concernant
les règles d'urbanisme
il permettra d'insérer les dispositions
relatives à l'implantation des
équipements utilisés dans les réseaux de
télécommunication et installations
radioélectriques qui sur importe l'avis
de la commission
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable se poser ici je mets aux
voix qui et pour qui contre l'amendement
309 n'est pas adoptée après rafik 15
vices un amendement 296 qu'il est
présenté par monsieur muller
je m'excuse mais j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il tombait dans la mesure où on
amendement vise à créer un chapitre est
bien compris il est tombé et nous
revenons à l'article 14 pour pour lequel
vous a dû être vous distribuer a dû être
distribués et doit être entre vos mains
un amendement 364 rectifiée présentée
par monsieur braille au nom de la
commission de l'économie
les deux sous amendement qui était celui
là l'est mme dupont il monsieur monsieur
de lège ont été retirés dans la mesure
où ils sont intégrés à cette nouvelle
rectification donc je vais appeler cet
amendement au vote
il aura comme conséquence s'il est
adopté de faire tomber tous les autres
et je prends maintenant les explications
de vote sur cet amendement devrait
rectifier
monsieur braille vous le présenter
rapidement puisque vous avez deviné la
quintessence et c'était l'écriture
monsieur le président je crois que j'ai
suffisamment expliqué la position la
commission il fait la synthèse
effectivement de ce que nous avons dit
avis conforme un délai de deux mois
je veux dire si le recours n'est pas
n'est pas examinée par le préfet de
région dans les deux mois
le recours est réputé positif monsieur
le ministre la vie du gouvernement je
m'en remets à la sagesse de la haute
assemblée merci à leurs explications de
vote jean pierre sueur
je dirais un peu coincé derrière et dc
je ne vous vois pas un grand manque pour
moi ne vous excusez pas ce n'est pas
grave non jouer simplement abondé dans
le sens de la proposition du rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
économiques
dire que je me rallie avec la commission
des affaires culturelles à la vie que
nous avons établi tous ensemble et que
et signalé que quand même nous faisons
partie et lui et monsieur d'auge et moi
de la commission tchô dont nous aurons
l'occasion de continuer à débattre pour
arriver à la meilleure solution et en
déduit que vous retirez le 68 rectifier
monsieur dupont il est retiré
alors monsieur le je crois qu'on est aux
explications de vote jean pierre sueur
je n'en vois pas d'autre merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues quelques mots au nom de
notre groupe socialiste
à cette heure tardive pour me dire
combien nous nous réjouissons de
l'accord qui a pu être trouvé sur ce
nouvel amendement numéro 3 164 rectifier
en effet mes chers collègues nous avons
considéré qu'il y avait une sorte de
tâche avec la disposition qui avait été
adopté par la commission mixte paritaire
sur le grenelle 1
en effet pour nous l'environnement
c'est bien sûr l'environnement naturel
mais c'est aussi le patrimoine mais
c'est aussi l'environnement urbain et il
était pour nous extrêmement choquant que
dans une loi sur l'environnement dans
une loi pour l'environnement soit adopté
une disposition qui en supprimant l'avis
conforme des architectes des bâtiments
de france avait pour effet à l'intérieur
des zppaup de les priver pratiquement de
tout pouvoir et par conséquent de priver
l'état de moyens la puissance publique
des moyens de mettre en oeuvre une
politique de protection effective du
patrimoine c'est pourquoi mes chers
collègues nous nous réjouissons vraiment
que cet amendement soit proposée il
reprend l'essentiel de l'amendement que
nous avions présenté avec monsieur
d'auge monsieur la gauche
madame tascam sur pantin monsieur raoul
et les membres de notre
groupe puisqu'il rétabli l'avis conforme
et cela a beaucoup de sens mais aussi
est un symbole puisque cela rétablit les
prérogatives de puissance publique par
rapport à cette impérieuse nécessité de
la protection du patrimoine
encore un mot pour dire que nous pensons
que la commission dont il a été beaucoup
question et qui a été mise en place par
le ministre de la culture sera peu utile
et qu'elle permettra nous le pensons
d'avancé en particulier sur les
modalités de recours nous considérons
qu'il est positif que le recours soit
effectué dans la nouvelle version qui
nous est présenté par le auprès du
préfet de région
c'est ce que nous avions proposé il nous
semble qu'il serait nécessaire que la
commission du patrimoine et des sites
soient consultés c'est sa fonction et il
est logique il puisse y avoir un avis
collégiale par rapport à ces questions
là mais nous pensons que la commission
pourra à cet égard faire des
propositions utiles
en tout cas c'est une un moment
symbolique et fort qui permet de revenir
sur une une décision qui avait été
extrêmement malencontreuse et j'espère
que nous serons suivis dans la suite du
débat à l'assemblée nationale lors de la
future commission mixte paritaire et
surtout par le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
suite aux travaux de la commission qui
va être mise en place voilà pourquoi
nous voterons bien entendu cet
amendement qui est le fruit d'un large
accord merci c'est sûr madame didier
pour l'explication de vote
oui monsieur le président merci je
souhaitais exprimer
la vie de notre groupe c'est un sujet
important nous sommes satisfaits de
l'avancée des travaux même si nous
savons que il faudra encore conforter
cette position avec les travaux de la
commission
mais nous espérons que les points de vue
du sénat et de l'assemblée seront
suffisamment proche pour que nous
puissions conserver le rôle des abf il
faut se rappeler que nous sommes tous
fiers de notre bâti que ce soit dans les
villages que ce soit dans les villes et
nul doute que cette qualité de notre
architecture soit due en partie au fait
qu'il y a il y a et qu'il y avait des
abf et donc nous sommes heureux de cette
conclusion qui je l'espère sera sera la
bonne et nous espérons que l'assemblée
nationale confortera ce travail de
consensus qui a été fait il ya là un
véritable consensus
le travail qui a été fait par la
commission comme par le gouvernement est
bien a été utile et nous vraiment
vraiment nous nous souhaitons que nous
en restions là et qu'il n'y ait pas des
retours malheureux qui fasse que nous
revenions en arrière merci chers
collègues je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement sur müller pour
l'explication de vote je vous en prie
monsieur univers
ce sera très bref pour expliquer ma
satisfaction je suis heureux de voir que
nous pouvons à certains moments être
unanime sans abstention pour aller dans
le même sens et et peser face à nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale notre
position permet de conforter la les
dispositions présente et d'améliorer le
dispositif en l'ouvrant à l'enjeu majeur
que constitue le développement des
énergies renouvelables y compris dans
ces zones là bien sûr c'est l'avenir qui
nous dira si on est unanime
monsieur l'hiver explications avec le
président ce ministre pour changer un
peu moi je dirais je partage pas tout à
fait votre point de vue je rappellerai
d'abord que les zppaup cesson demandé et
il est normal que les municipalités
soient concernés pour demander une
zppaup
si on la demande c'est bien parce qu'on
a envie de réfléchir avec des gens
administration qui nous entourent mais
de là à revenir à dix avis conforme sur
lesquels nous avons passé des débats ici
très important et à plusieurs reprises
pour éviter justement que l'erreur
humaine étant ce qu'elle est les hommes
et où les femmes et ans que ce que nous
sommes les humains des humains et bien
font souvent des erreurs que nous payons
cher que nous payons cher parce que nous
attendons des mois voire des années
quelques fois et que étant dans un
village classé monument historique
je peux vous dire combien nous souffrons
de cela alors moi je veux bien si si la
majorité a pensé qu'il fallait revoir ça
n'encense la majorité nous sommes ici je
ne parle pas majorité politique
eh bien je veux bien après tout accepter
ça mais je veux quand même pouvoir dire
que ce n'est pas pour moi une avancée ce
n'est peut-être pas non plus un retour
en arrière
jean tampon j'entends par là que si nous
pouvions définir au sein d'une
commission à voix égales obtenir un
obtenir un avis général des opérations
ouvrir un débat préparer un certain
nombre d'éléments nouveaux dont on a
besoin
beau réfléchir à tout ça je dis oui mais
est à plat ventre devant une personne et
nous en avons connus chez moi et
ailleurs qui fait des excès de pouvoir
ce n'est pas non plus acceptable
sans parler de pillage des alliés oui
justement ce président en fait c'est un
bon compromis et l'essentiel c'est que
nous sortions de ce débat avec un avis
conforme des abf et je crois que c'est
un bon support cet amendement est un bon
support pour le démarrage des travaux de
la future commission donc moi je voterai
évidemment cet amendement très bien je
si je veux mettre aux voix
l'amendement 350 64 rectifiée présentée
par dominique braille qui et pour qui
contre et donc l'amendement est adopté
et l'article est bien sûr adopté il nous
reste très peu de choses
après l'article 14 monsieur de lège à un
amendement 113 rectifie ont été
rectifiés mais nous en distribuer en
conséquence de ce qu'ils veulent et
adopté monsieur de lège sur le 113
rectifier merci monsieur le président en
fait l'article que nous venons de
l'adopter traite des ppp mais les atp
upc fille sans nous ont effectivement
existantes
ce sont 400 en cours de d'élaboration
mais les sites classés sont à peu près
au nombre de trente mille et donc en
réglant le problème des effets pays paie
on a certainement régler une partie des
problèmes mais pas l'intégralité est
donc l'objet de l'article de
l'amendement 113 et l'amendement 114,6
vont autoriser à les rapporter en même
temps puisqu'ils sont identiques
le 113 a trait aux périmètres de
protection et le 114 au secteur
sauvegardé
ces deux amendements pour objectif de
partir de ce que nous venons de voter et
de l'étendre c'est à dire premièrement
premièrement introduire un délai le
délai de deux mois
ce que nous venons de faire pour les
zppaup deuxièmement inversé comme nous
l'avons fait pour les ailes ppip la
charge de la preuve si je fasse il
exprimé c'est à dire qu'au bout de deux
mois si le préfet n'a pas répondu
le recours est présumé acquis
troisièmement nous proposons de
supprimer le pouvoir d'évocation du
ministre considérant qu'au fond il a à
sa disposition des services en région
directeur du patrimoine où le préfet de
région et bien évidemment dans ce cas là
nous insistons beaucoup bien sûr pour le
maintien de la vie confort mais aussi
pour le maintien de la commission car
autant dans la zppaup
on peut avoir un débat sur la nécessité
de matière la consulter la commission
pourquoi parce que là cette ppl ps en
quelque sorte un contrat entre le maire
et la bf
il ya déjà eu un travail à une carte ya
un règlement et donc en quelque sorte
cette commission s'est déjà réuni s'est
déjà prononcée et d'ailleurs il ya très
peu de contentieux dans les zppaup
france rac 1 à 3 jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'instant en revanche lorsqu'on est en
secteur protégé ses 30000 site que
j'évoquais je crois qu'il est important
non seulement garder la vie conforme
mais d'avoir l'éclairage de la
commission donc voilà l'objet de l'art
de l'amendement 113 et l'amendement 114
encore une fois c'est le même mais cette
fois ci pour les sites très bien merci
le sud de l'aisne je vais donc demander
l'avis du rapporteur sur le 113 et sur
le circuit sur 214 va dire que ces
dispositions sont très pertinentes et en
tout cas très attendue par les élus
donc c'est un avis favorable merci sera
vôtre monsieur le ministre
oui même position que tout à l'heure
c'est à dire sagesse nous attendons
évidemment pour ce qui nous concerne la
mission confiée au conseiller d'état
tio pour effectivement avoir une
position définitive je vous remercie
monsieur me soumet aux voix la maman
sont présents rectifié explications de
vote
sur bien donc il ya plus d'explications
de vote
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre alors
113 rectifié genevois qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est adopté 114 rectifié qui pour les
contres il est adopté a pris que 15
monsieur delaigue remplacer changement
des références oui premièrement
remplacement de référence et
deuxièmement l'application à mayotte de
ce que nous venons de voter pour les atp
tant qu'une coordination ses rapporteurs
favorable ce procès le ministre cg c'est
leur jeu mais rejoint le moment 115 qui
et pour qui contre et adopté l'article
15 je me vois l'article 15 qui et pour
qui et contre l'article 15 est adoptée
nous en avons terminé l'examen du titre
1er du projet de loi portant engagement
national pour l'environnement je vous
rappelle que la conférence des
présidents a prévu la poursuite de
l'examen ce projet doit partir du lundi
28 septembre à 14h30
vous venez de revoir une partie de
l'examen du projet de loi grenelle 2 je
vous donne rendez-vous lundi à 16h30
pour la lecture des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi hadopi merci de votre fidélité
excellent week end à tous et à très
bientôt sur public sénat